let's talk a little bit about
politicians then speaking above ratings
and
the ability to get someone to tell the
truth baby often I now see these
interview shows and politicians
have a way up no matter what you as the
interviewer asked they answer completely
different question and
and they shamelessly do it how to use or
directly honest
get shoved to the side would occur barry
goldwater
and george mcgovern were two classic
examples by going to be the both many
times
and both Pestano barry goldwater on
george mcgovern had no cut-off
between the brain and the mob wrestle
question-and-answer
right wiped out in national elections
because the public
and the we we in the media say we want
their a donde sea and we'll ambassador
if you directly on so what the
politician tries to do
is home to my season pretty the best tip
anybody if you're watching an interview
show the politicians and the
a guest is as the question and the
politicians
those I'm glad you escalate is the truth
he sold me not to administer and he has
said I'm glad US that
so he can think how to answer it that
will appeal to the largest common
to nominate so I'm guessing you probably
heard that about four billion time
within 25 years on CNN right now don't
you do the best you can
what I try to do is get a pic or two
things I tried as good questions
come around a lot always but I on the
other hand
no great respect for politicians for
this reason
they do something that we don't do one
they stand up and be counted
and they have what we now have never had
in our lives
they have a Tuesday in November where
the school goes up
and we don't do that we have ratings but
that sporadic
correct score goes up so I've always
respected politicians and athletes
athletes have something we don't have
one
their livelihood ends when most of our
really good livelihood begins
the cheering stops when their 40
archie rings in life starts at forty
pretty much number two they have a final
score
you know aidid you lost
you know we don't have a final score
yeah I mean blooms for three today
somebody laws for some we played best
Wallace and the one team scored a 100
2011 team scored 97
you can call you want the people on 97
lost the loss to is that it right there
is that the problem with the media that
we don't score things the other
I respect at least because they face
that yeah iris but politicians because
they get a Tuesday November
that we don't have so I begin with all
respect for a man to read for
then I can if he gets drawn to store off
the beaten track then
you know you tried it I you try to learn
as much as you can also try to do in
interviewing was learn as much as I can
when I yelled at people
I never learned anything the up